[Music]
yes all this well this is dirty like
German exchange student arrives in Tokyo
orders pizza and can't pay it for dirty
yet tonight's episode of blackish now
the ABC hit could clean up but the
Golden Globe this Sunday and that is
because the show was nominated and so
are the stars Tracee Ellis Ross and
Anthony Anderson they are my favorites I
have to admit it nazar but you know what
the interesting thing is Anthony may not
be the funniest person in his own real
life family ladies and gentlemen I give
you
mama Doris Happy New Year what a damn
camera Carolla oh it wasn't too long
before I found out if you want the truth
go to mama Doris how you spend holidays
the party was at my house this year
oh wait a minute where was my invite
hell I don't know you miss Doris sure
keeps it real lon to tell the truth why
in the hell that y'all go to the forest
to job providing a running commentary to
her son the hopes holiday you think you
can tell when people are actually lying
or when I'm lying you like to tell a lie
now why in the world would you all
decide let's work together let's not
only be mother and son didn't work
together to work with this everybody say
I'm funnier than he is he just give
jealous and take a look at the tape I
was about to say I love you okay oh
that's a lie
tell me this have you been recognized
yet to be altered
five girls ran after me oh what the hell
happened and then all of a sudden one of
the girls say mama dog has Anthony
always been funny yes since he was 18
months old
18 months yeah what did he do that he
was most funny at 18 months he went to
sleep standing up in the middle of his
play yo Christmas play I got pictures
Anthony actually got the acting bug
while watching mama Doris on stage
rehearsing our Raisin in the Sun and I
looked up and I said that's what I'm
gonna do with the rest of my life and
I'm why any applause I got where have
you been hiding this woman she is a star
you know why I'm natural and you gotta
have a script of course you gonna be
better come on we'll come up come on hey
ain't no acting to it I'm real and that
was miss Doris sitting next to Amy
Schumer at the Emmys read any more juice
pop you were like a juice box
there you go that night Anthony didn't
win a statuette I dropped the tear
during the commercial break and I don't
know what that was from I had to gather
myself I wasn't from Miss door he knows
he's got another chance at this Sunday's
Golden Globes but Miss Doris will not be
his date I've took you to the Emmys mama
you can't go everywhere with me
Amy Schumer's gonna be there me and she
love you calling me Amy hook my mama
would go to globe see because I'm tapped
out I'm sorry